ではよろしくお願いします
かなり遅くなりましたけど
早速始まります で まあ一応タイトルはまあそういうもので
で 今日の大会を社会人とか世間知らずとか
そういうのを理解する前に
あのちょこっとした単語を 2つ専門用語を教えまして
まずそこの説明に入ります
一番はこの内向性というね
まあ人間によくある問題で
まあ内向性っていうのは社会に他人に接することに自信を持てないとかね
あるいは恥ずかしく思う
人と接することっていうのは
なんかすごく恥ずかしくて
という性格ですね あるいは avoid 怖がる
社会に接することは まあそこは全部もう内向性ということですね
自分の内なる世界で忙しく
他人のことを気にする余裕はありません
もう一つっていうのは
もう自分の頭の中でもいろいろなことがあって
精一杯ずっと性格なんですね
子供の頃から自分のことで精一杯で
社会のことを気にする余裕がなくなるというちょこっとした精神的な状態なんですね
で 他人との関係は悪くなる
そういうことで まあ他人との関係は持てなくなっちゃうんですね
それは内向性の特色なんです
皆様 心理学的なところはかなり詳しいんですから
私は心理学を勉強したことないので
まあそこはその程度にいたします
で 社会の役に立てない人になる
結果として 内向性の人間というのは社会の役に立てない人間になってしまいます
それはもう内向性の問題で
さらにあります  社会が複雑になると
巨大化すると そうですね
内向性の人間も増えてしまうんですね
それでこれ ちょこっとあの
今まで説明してきたのは
まあ昔からあることで
今 現代社会を見ると もう社会はどんどん複雑化していくし
いろいろ変わっていくでしょうし
まあそうなってくると
この内向性の人間っていうのはみるみるうちに増えてしまいますよ
それはまあ大変 内向性そのものが悪いんだからね
だから社会が発展するということは結構やばいんですよ
人間っていうのは結構内向性になってしまうんですね
自分だけの世界を作って時間を潰すんですよ
まあ一番わかりやすい例で言えば
例えばインドとか自分の国とか
まあどうせもうやることろくなものがない場合は
みんなかなり社会には興味を持ってるんですね
特に政治家なんか来て喋るんだ
講演するんだというと
もうすごい人々が集まるんです
もう警察も動かない 動いてくれないと
特別交通便を作ってあげないと
もう人々大変ですよ もう軽々と
まあインドだったらもうもう何 100万人ですけど
自分の国では軽々ともう 10 万
20 万集まるんですよ
やることないんです あの人々に
それにしたら日本のもうなんかもう総理大臣喋ろうか
もう誰が喋ろうか まあせいぜい 10人
20人ぐらい この駅の前で
まあそれも関係のある人々はどうしようもなくビラを持って待ってるだけで
一般人は全然聞いてないんですよ
もう興味もない もうさっさと電車に乗って出て行っちゃうんです
だからまあ その 2つ比べてみると
もう試しにちょっと戦争
選挙なんかあるときは
大体外国旅行しない方がいいかもしれませんだけど
まあそんなに危険でもないんだけど
結構大変ですよ もうかなりもうもう大変
まあ来る  この間インドに行った時も
選挙の時期で もう何時間も道路で車が渋滞状態で待たされるんですよ
だからまあみんな車もで
もう行列作っていくわ
いくわ いくわ もうキリがない
まあそこまでよく暇があるもんだなと思いますよ
自分の国も同じで まあ政治家が選挙運動やってるんだったら
まあ他人間他のことをやらない
そればっかりで あの雰囲気が気分がいいし
あの人と喋ることも聞いて楽しいし
で まあ行列とかなんとかデモとかやってね
それで楽しんじゃうんですよ
だから全く知らない人々でも
その時会って仲良くしたりする
なんかすごい外向性で見られますけど
あれは社会はまだまだ発展していないんだからなんです
例えば日本みたいな社会になってくると
もう駅の前でまあ 40人でも集めてもらえば
どうしたもん どうしたもんですよ
大したもんですよ もう誰も聞いてくれない
もう結構喋ってる相手がかなり有名人で
もう立派な方々なんですけど
だからどういうことかというと
この社会はあまりにも複雑で
もう現代社会だから 結局みんな内向性になってるんです
興味ないと関係ないんだと
だからまあ大体この社会が複雑になると
結局みんな暗い内向性の人間になってしまうんです
テレビ ゲーム 携帯電話
インターネットなどが相手になるんですよ
これがすごい明白  こういうことで
病気かないかよくわかるんですね
でも あの携帯っていうのはなんか体の一部みたいでね
離れないでしょうね 電車に座って
もう携帯を持って何やってるんですかと
階段上がる時でも携帯で
エスカレーターの時でも携帯で
エレベーターの時でもエレベーターのドア開けてるのにやってるんです
私は困るのはこのエスカレーターなんですよ
勝手に死ねばいいんだけど
こっちは死にたくないんだからね
そこでもやってもう降りない
だからあの動くあれがもう中でしっかりと入ってるんだから
自動的に位置に立つでしょうね
それでも後ろから来る人上がってくるんだから
すごい面白いんです だから私はエスカレーターだったら必ず登る
もう年なんですけど 膝も痛いし
あの精神的にイカれてる人々にも付き合えませんだからね
こちら怪我するんだから
だからいくらものすごい
まあかなりもう長い長い
もうエスカレーターいっぱいあるでしょうね
エレベーターエスカレーターが
まあしょうがないんですよ
もう息切れ 息が切れてるのに
とにかく登る 命守るために
そこでやがて心臓発作を起こして死んでるかもしれませんだけど
だからまあ そういうもので
みんなこの結構忙しくするんですよ
特にこれ インターネットの場合は
よく社会とつながってるとえらい勘違いしてるんですよ
いろんなブログやらチャットやら
いろんなものを作って
すぐ何人かで同じ病気の仲間がもう言いたい放題のことを言っている
でも自分一人だから 相手が機械だから
人と対話したことにならないんです
我では 相手が返事したっても
これは電子信号で出てくる文字でしょうね
そこを見て読んで何でも言えますからね
そこで人を見ると もう怯えて震えて冷や汗が出て
大変です それにどこかに隠れて暗闇に入れておいて
コンピューター一つあげちゃえば
まあ書くことは 言うことはもう切りがないという
だからそれもこの精神的な病気ということになるんです
いわゆる内向性の問題なんです
で これで錯覚を起こすんですよ
世界と繋げられているんだと
携帯持っちゃうと まあ世界と私は繋げているんだから
私はそれなりに世界人やと
と そういうことになるんです
社会と繋がっていると錯覚を起こしているんですね
本当は全く繋がってないんですが
そういう錯覚を起こすんです
人格は徐々に落ちていく
だから内向性の場合はどんどん人格
人間としての人格 能力
どんどん減って減って
もう危ないことになるんです
それからそちらの反対のエクストロバートということは
外向性の場合はどうなるのかと
で まあ一応表面的に見れば社会性があり
まあ行動的ですね かなり行動的
社会からの反応は自分の生き甲斐です
まあ外向性もこの講演ではあまりありがたく褒めませんが
あの皆様の場合は外向性ってありがたいと思っているかもしれませんだけど
そこら辺初めから理解してください
こちらではあまり褒めません
内向性に行ったと同じく
外向性にもいろいろ言うんです
で この外向性の人々にとっては
この社会が自分の生きがいなんですね
社会が褒めてくれることやら
まああれやこれやとかね
動かずにいられない なんかやらずにはいられない
なんか変ですよ 社会の表面しか知らない
それで社会のことを知ってるかで
それはどうでもいいんで
ただ動くだけだからね
で 動いてみんな圧倒されて驚かせちゃって
例えば迷惑かけても 相手がありがとうございます
助かりましたと言わなくちゃいけないですよね
本当は無茶迷惑かけてますけどね
だからまあそれも結構病気なんです
で 社会の表面しか知らない
相手の気持ちなどはほとんど気にしない
この外向性の人々っていうのは
能力があってもなくても
自分が勝手に出て仕事をする
自分にできるかないか
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
じゃあ私がやりますと
もうすぐもうやっているんです
えらい迷惑なんですよ
何かもうまあまあ 社会とか何か
まあこういうことをしてもしなくちゃいけない
でも喋って終わってもないのに
まあこうこう もうこれじゃあ私やる
やってるんです 何やってるか本人もわからないんです
特にそういう外向性の人っていうのは
もうもうもうかなり遠ざかった方がいいと思いますよ
すごい危ない もう何でも壊す組織なんかは
それによって社会が受ける迷惑
損なんかは一向に構わない
そういう外向性の人々は自分で動くだけで
まあ小泉さんの行政改革と同じなんですね
政治改革出て 彼がそれしか知らないんですね
あまり勉強してないみたい
政治とか知らないんで
だからとにかく私は政治改革するんだぞと
全てされて言って あれだけやるんだと
同じ政治家が自分のところもいたんですよ
あの自分の個人的な財産
まあちょっと危うく状態になっちゃって
このいろいろ法律を変えて
あの税金システム変えたりすると
そちらはもう 1円も税金払いたくない
だから特別法律作って
自分たちの個人財産が増える一方で減らないようにしていたんです
それで政権変わったところで
これではダメやと もう誰でも同じ法律でやるぞというところで
自分たちの財産がからの税金払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんで
それで民主主義はなくなった
この国はもう共産主義になりました
これ独裁政権だ あれやこれやと言って
一般人をもう動かしちゃって
暴動を起こして 次の選挙で勝ったんです
私たちはもう正義の味方で
もうみんなに正しい政権をするんだぞと言って
あの自分の財産 全部政府
政府に取られたものを全部戻してもらって
自分たちがまた税金を払わないように設定させたんです
それで これで世界は救われたと表現したんです
だから結局自分のことなんですよ
だからまあ同じ まあ政治家といえば誰でも同じもんでね
まあまあ そちらの方々はいくらの町なんですけど
どちらにしても まあ我々困るのは我々の普通の社会とか家族とか
普通の仲間の間なんですよ
政治家は政治家なりに
いろいろ もうまあそうまんざらバカでもないんだからね
まあまあ それでまあ人にはどんな影響あるかどうか
それはどうでもいいことで
まあ自分で動くだけ 他人の仕事に強引に手を出して邪魔をするか
自分で奪う まあ他人が仕事をしていると
そちらには何々何々って言って
そちらにも手を出す で
やってあげましょうかとかね
それあるいは奪ったりする
やってる人はそれ能力あるんだから
仕事やってるんであって
まあただ邪魔をするだけなんです
まあ本人はただこの何かやらないと生きていられない
すごい精神的な病気にかかっているんです
だから そういった人は社会にいるんじゃなくて
病院にいた方が 病院で永久保存してもらっちゃえばいいんだけど
もう役に立たないんです
でも社会でものすごく動いてるんだから
そうなっちゃいますよ
本人は別にそういうつもりじゃないんです
病気だから もう何かに手を出さないと
何かに口を挟まないと
もう生きていられないんです
物事を理解しないという対策によって行動力を維持する
だから こういう人々はどうやってあれほどみんなに嫌がられるのに
あれほど嫌味を言われているのに
かなり嫌味言われますよ
結構無視されます だって邪魔だから
人からいくら いくら嫌味を言われても
いくら邪魔扱いされてもめげません
それでも淡々と自分の行動をやっている
あれってすごい精神 すごい強いように感じるでしょ
違うんです 物事を理解しないんですよ
だから大丈夫ですよ 面と向かって言っても
あ そうかそうかと言ってまた動くんです
理解しないんですよ 例えば自分がもう協力しようというでと言ったら
相手があれね あんたは協力じゃなくてかなり邪魔だからね
あ そうだ そうか はい わかりました
じゃあ協力しますと またやるんです
同じことですけど 理解しないんですよ
だから物事を理解しないことで自分の行動力を維持するんです
理解するとそれほど行動することはできなくなるんだからね
人の気持ちも考えなくちゃいけないんだからね
無知は際立つんですね
社会に寄生する存在です
外向性は これから次にまたいるんですよ
この中間性 普通に人間は中間的ですよ
だいたい内向性 外向性
というのは まあまあ  50人に一人いたってもえらい迷惑なんですけども
モテませんよ もう10人に二人
三人いちゃうと もう全部壊れます
まあ内向性は内向性で暗くて控えめでいるんだから
このまあ自分だけ破壊するんであって
まあそんなに相手に問題ない場合もありますけど
外向性はそうじゃないんですよ
もう何でも壊していくんだから
100人に一人いたっても結構大変だと思いますよ
外交的な人が でも社会は人間っていうのはそういうその極端ではなくて
ほとんど中間的なんですね
この英語でいうミディアムですね
そのレベルなんですね
これはとてもよくできている方だと思っているんですよ
だから みんなもうまあそこそこ頑張っているんだから
すごいよくできた方だと優等生だと思っているんですね
この中間は しかし 社会に対する適応性について疑問を抱くのは中間性の人々ですよ
自分たちが優等生だという感じで
社会で問題を起こさず
あまり出しゃばりもしないで
あまりも引くこともしないで
適当にやっているんだと
優等生でしょ でも 人間関係
社会関係についてごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ文句を言うのはそういう人々なんです
あの外向性は言わないんです
どうせもともとアホだからね
で 内向性はもうそうっと社会に出ませんだからね
まあ嫌やと言って引っ込めてるんだから問題ないんですよ
だからもう社会とうまくいかないんだとかね
どうすればもう会社の仲間とうまくいけるんでしょうかとか
あれこれやといっぱい問題作って
もうディスカッションするわ
本作るわ 本読むわ カウンセリングする受けるわ
やりたい放題全部やってるのはこの中間なんですよ
あの極端の 2つじゃないんです
内向性は関係は持ちたくない
だから問題ありません
外向性は自分の無知に決して気づかない
もう動く だからどうすればよりより社会的社会に貢献できるのか
一度も考えませんだから外向性は
ただ無知だから動くんだから
例えば人にいじめられたっても
別に知らない そんなことまだ行動しているんだから
迷惑をかけ続けているんだからね
だから外向性はあんまり
そういうことで自分で問題を作らない
中間が問題ですよ 内向性と外向性との程よい位置はわからない
この中間性の人々は まあ適当に内向的で適当に外向的でしょ
それで程よい位置はどれぐらいかと
これわからないんですよ
どこまで控えて どこまで喋りがいいかわからないんですよ
例えば一番誰でも経験ある例で言えば
例えば子供をしつけるとか叱るとかね
どこまで言えばいいか
どこまで黙っていた方がいいかわからないでしょ
黙っていても子供はそれほどのこと育ちますけど
でも黙っていただけでもダメですね
叱らないことあったら言ってあげなくちゃいけないし
これ程よい位置は知らないんですよ
誰でも 黙っていようかなと思ったら
無視し無視しすぎになっちゃうし
子供のこと 言おうと思っちゃうと言い過ぎ
そういうことになっちゃうんですね
だからもう知ってはいるんだけど
この程よい位置が知らないんですよ
だからいつでも何かトラブルが起こしてトラブルを起こしちゃうんですよ
自分の能力によって位置が定められてしまいます
また 人間の能力あるでしょう
その能力によって この内向性から外向性までの間で
どこかに自分の位置が止まっちゃうんですよ
まあ言ってることはそれほど難しくないんだけどね
まあ内向性は極端で 外向性も極端で
我々一般人が自分持っている能力によって
どちらでちょうど真ん中じゃないんです
どこかにいるんですよ
例えば自分では内向的な方がちょこっと強いんだったら
やっぱり内向の方に寄り寄ってますね
外向的な性格の方が多いんだったら
そちらに寄っちゃいますね
だから自分の位置が自分の能力でピタッと決めてしまうんですね
中間の人々の場合は これでどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからみんなそれを感じていると思います
まあどうにもならんやと
いくら頑張ってもそんなもんやと
大体まあ なんか全部もう固定しているのではないかなと
まあ例えば 20 人と仲良くして付き合うことに能力がない人は
まあ 5人だったら結構落ち着くでしょ
ならばね 落ち着くならば
その人はもう何やっても大体 5人か 5人以下になるんです
例えば会社を始めたとする
うまくいっている うまくいっていると
新しい人々を雇ったりして
会社を 何といいますか
伸ばさなくちゃあかんでしょう
でも自分には 5人の管理しかできないんですよ 10
人になってくると もう興奮しちゃって
混乱しちゃって 何が何だかわからなくなるんだから
そういう人は決してその会社を伸ばそうとしないんです
どうしても会社というのは社会なもんだから
伸ばすときは伸ばしてしまいます
否応なしにいい会社だったら
その場合は自分が辞退するんです
せっかく自分が作った会社なのに
自分の精神的な立場は常に揺らいでいます
それでもういろんな社会のことを考えたりとかするんだから
精神的に揺らいでいます
例えばすごく繁栄している会社なんですけど
今もうエンパイアというか
まあ 5人でやっていると
社員が 5 人ではダメだな
こんな仕事量だからね
やっぱりもうこれはもう 10人にしなきゃという
計算してもわかるんだけど
10人あればいいんだけど
もうどうしよう それで揺らぐんですよ
精神は 雇いたいんだけど
もう 10人の社長にはなれないんですね 5
人だったら社長にはなれます
そこで本人が精神的に揺らいだりする
例えばお母さんたちがね
まあ子供は叱るべきか
黙っていくべきか 親切にするべきか
どうしようかなとか いつでも悩んでるんですよ
万引きでもしちゃったら
もう怒鳴るべきか それ無視して可愛いことやってあげるかもわからないんですよ
とにかく子供は万引きした
これが悪い なんとかしなくちゃいけないってことだけは知ってるんだけど
どう対応すればいいかっていうことはわからなくなっちゃうんです
そこで精神的にも常に揺らぐ
これは中間の問題なんですね
大体いろいろ組織なんかもうやがて潰れるのはそういうわけでね
まあ初めは 10人で  20人で小さなスケールで始めて
まあ結構うまくいっている
ごまかしもないし 不正もないし
脅しもないし そこで精神的に揺らいで
なんで 20人？これはもう 40人にしましょうと
で  40人にしようとする
なんで 40人？これはもう
人にしようかなと でも自分には人にさせる能力がないんだから
この自分の仲間にもっともっとメンバーを探せとかね
そうしたら仲間たちは自分たちのやり方でまた仲間を探して入れたりするし
それでもともとの組織の決まり
全部もう壊れているんですよ
本人には何の権利も管理もなく
能力もなくなってしまって
やがて壊れて犯罪まで起こし終わっちゃうんですね
こういうことになるのは
この精神的な揺らぎが働くんだからなんです
ストレスは溜まるが 知恵は現れません
この中間的に生きると
結構ストレスだけは溜まりますよ
だから人と付き合わなくちゃいけないし
同時にあまり出しゃばりは良くないと思ってるし
もうとにかくとにかく間に合った人々といろんなことで会社で仕事をするわ
家庭の面倒見などいろいろやってるんだから
ストレス溜まるんですよ
しかし 知恵が開花しないんですね
こうすればいい こうすればいいという知恵が出てこないんです
で もう一度内向性に戻ります
で 自己観察 自分発見などはとても良いことですが
内向性はそれを行っているのではありません
内向性の人は自分のことで精一杯でしょう
だったらありがたいでしょうね
でも あの人々は自己観察してるわけじゃないんです
強烈な自我意識で妄想妄想しているだけ
で なぜならば この中間性の人々から見れば
あの人はもう内向性でとてもいい人やとと言うかもしれません
でもそれは間違いなんです
自己観察は仏教で言っている素晴らしい行為なんですよ
知恵が現れる行為なんです
内向性は自己観察しているわけじゃなくて
自我意識があまりも強烈で
もう我慢できない自我意識が
それで妄想しているんです
生命エネルギーが また間違えていますね
浪費してしまって元気ではありません
行動できません それで妄想するんだから
もう命とエネルギーがもう全くなくなっちゃうんですね
だから元気じゃないんですよ
人と挨拶したいんだけど
お母さんも言ってるんだから
まあわかってはいるんだけど
挨拶しなくちゃいけないんだ
でも元気じゃないんですよ
部屋から出られないんです
あまりにも厳しいお母さんだったら
挨拶こんにちはと言ってすぐ逃げるんです
もうエネルギーがないんです
で なぜかというと 妄想で生命エネルギーが全部浪費しています
行動できません 煩悩が激しくなり
罪を犯すこともあり得る
この内向の人々が 自分で自画で妄想しているんだから
もう椅子から立ちません
ベッドに横になったら
そこで 1 日中でもベッドでいて
ゲームやったり遊んだりしていますよ
そうすると何も動かないんだから安全だと思うでしょうね
違うんです えらい危険ですよ
煩悩がどんどんどんどん大きくなって
自分でも何もするもう我慢できなくなって犯罪を起こしちゃうんです
結構いるでしょ 内向性の人々は人を殺したりとかね
子供なのに 15 歳なのに人を殺したとか
親殺したとかね いるんですよ
だから内向性は何も動かないんだから
心配は安心だとということはないんです
黙ってはいるんだけど
突然包丁を持って外へ出て
人二人ぐらい殺して 何のことなく家に帰ってるかもしれませんよ
たった 10 分  20 分の出来事で
それで親もびっくりするにも
この子はずっと 2 年間も家を出たことがないんだと
そんなことありえないんだと
もう頼んでも頼んでも買い物に一緒に行こうかと言ってても来ないんだと
それは嘘やと親が思うかもしれませんだけど
でもその子は部屋でじーっとまで突然立ち上がって
包丁でもってさっさとどこへ誰か刺して
また何のことなく家にいて
また落ち込んでいるんです
落ち込むではなくて 部屋にもう引き込んでいるんですよ
でも人が死んでいる 調べるともう証拠はあるんだから
まあこの人だという見つかっちゃうんです
それで心理学者やらカウンセラーやら親やら
全然わからない なんでこんなことになるのかさっぱりわからないとか
まあ喋るだけで話が終わるんです
それで外向性の次に戻ってみると
また危険なところがあってね
心の中の不安 恐怖に気づくので
外の世界に挑戦する これ
逃げる行為なんですね
この外向性っていう人々っていうのは
なんかすごい恐怖感があるんですよ
あの 試しにこのものすごい明るくて
この行動する この笑い芸人なんかいるでしょ
とにかく人を笑わせる
そのと個人的に聞いてみてください
なんで一人になれないのかと
一人になれないんですよ
一人になるとものすごい不安なんです
で 結構まあ聞いて調べたところあります
それはなんであんたそんなに明るいのかと
もう黙っていると不安だと
何か冗談でも言わないと不安だと
だから自分には心の中で不安があって
恐怖感があって そこで動くんですよ
いろいろ旅行計画立てるは
まあ大変です とにかくあれこれとね
まあ踊り大会でもやろうではないかとかね
何もなかったら まあもうお菓子食べる会でも作りましょうと
そこで会を作って 日本中回って
各地方のお菓子食べてお茶を飲む会
そういうものもありますからね
もう何でも会になるんです
もうなんでそんなにもうどうでもいいくだらんことまでもう会ができるのかというと
みんな外向性で 結構精神的に病気なんです
一人ではいられません
だから何かに逃げる それから次の問題は
高慢と欲か怒りの衝動で活発になることもある
また別の人々 えらい高慢で
我こそ世界一や日本一やとかね
もう私なら何でもできるぞという高慢ね
もうどっち何にでも手を出して全部壊す
私 私ならできるぞと言って
まあそういう高慢あるいは欲があって
私がそれをやった方が自分にとってはいいやとかね
まあ人が仕事をして昼までじーっと待っていて
終わったらさっさと自分が持ってて
あれ これ仕事終わりましたけどと上司に報告したりするんですよ
やっとな別な人なんですけど
で そういう のは まあよくありますからね
まあそれはまあ欲ですね
外の社会に依存して生きているので
一人になるとかなり弱い
危ない この外向性の人々っていうのは
一人にさせるとかなり危ないんですよ
というか すごく弱くなるんです
内向性は まあ結構人を殺したり犯罪を起こしたりしますけども
外向性も結構弱いことにはなります
ますもうすごく気が弱くなるんですよ
まあ皆様のまあ具体的な例で言えばわかると思う
会社でバリバリ仕事をして明るくいたいたという方々は
そこで会社辞めるでしょ
それと同時に人生も辞めてしまうでしょ
何もできなくなっちゃって
つまらなくて これで大変トラブルを起こしたりとかね
病気になったりと そういうケースあるんじゃないんですか
それは外向性の問題なんで
外向性で会社に依存して
自分がすごく明るく元気で会社のために働いてたんです
でも自分は精神的に問題があったんで
外向性という それでどうせ会社っていうのはやがて辞めなくちゃあかんでしょうね
辞めて家に帰ったところでどうしようかと
毎日朝時半に出かけてるのに
もう時半に出かけなくてもいいし
もうもうさっさとご飯食べて出かけたのに
奥さん別にもう気にしないでのんびり
もうご飯作ってるんだから
もうイライラする なんであんた早く別に早くなく早くなくたっていいんじゃないかな
そちら言うかもしれませんし
だからなんかいても立ってもいられなくなって
かなり精神的な問題を作っちゃいます
だからまあ それで弱くなるんですよ
無知に支配される 智慧が現れない
まあまあ だからこれ 無知に支配されているということで
人間として必要な智慧っていうのは
外向性の病気にかかっちゃうとどうしても出てこない
これでもう2回も内向性外向性にある危険性問題を説明しました
なぜかというと 中間性を理解するためなんです
中間性にもまあ以上の極端な悪の適当な組み合わせですね
中間性っていうのは だからまあまあ
その他大勢の方々は中間性ですけど
あまりこの優等生だと自慢できませんよ
ただ適当にあの合わせて組み合わせているんです
精神的に舞い上がったり落ち込んだりでしょ
普通の人々は自信が出たり消えたりでしょ
時々自信があって 時々自信がないとかね
自分の気持ち次第で内向的になったり
外向的になったりするので
頼りにならないでしょ
だいたい一般の人っていうのは頼りにならない
本人の気分次第でやってくれる時もあるし
いやいや 私はもう忙しいんだからと言って引き始める時もあるし
わからないんですよ 人の気持ち次第で
相手自分の気持ち次第で内向性になったり
外向性になったりとか
もうむちゃむちゃ だから常に精神が揺らいでますよ
だから どんな人にあなた自信ありますか？と聞いちゃうと
あるとも言えない ないとも言えないでしょうね
場合によって自信がある時もあるし
場合によって全く自信がなくなったりすることもあるし
時々自信があってビシビシ頑張ったのに
何か出来事を起きたところで全く自信がなくなったと
もう立ち直れなくなったとか
そうやって結局はもうトラブルを作っちゃうんですよ
問題を引き起こしちゃうんですね
これが中間性の場合ですね
また 他人の顔色をうかがって生きる
これもよくやってますね
他人どうでしょうどうか
それだけ見て真似するんですね
それで智慧と人格は向上しないんですよ
自分で考えて行動していないんだから
まああの人はやってるんだよ
私もやりますと どうても他人のことばっかり気にして自分を調整しようとしているんだから
智慧も智慧はないんですよ
人格は全然向上しない
これが中間性の問題なんです
だから中間性はあまりこの犯罪を起こしたり
人を殺したりはしないんです
あれは極端な人々なんです
中間性も まあこの極端になったらわかりませんだけど
まあ大体はもう 文句言いながらストレス溜まりながら
もう精神の先生の薬飲みながら
まあなんとかなんとか間に合って頑張ってはいるんです
だからこれわかりやすく言えば
まあまあ小心士か あれ
溺死かということになるんですよ
まあどちらでもどうしたことないんですけどね
この中間の で 社会と関わりながら生きる上で
以上説明した 3つの方法も正しくないんです
今 人間関係の場合は 3つ言ったんですね
外向性 内向性 中間性 イントロバース
エクストロバート ミディオバートという 3つ
どちらでも正しくないです
わかるでしょう？どちらでもろくなものじゃないんです
中間性は極端性を批判したり
助けようとしたりするが
極端性は極めて少ない
この我々中間性の人間はよく批判してるでしょ
この極端な人を あの人出過ぎやと
あんなのやり過ぎやと
なんであんなことをするんですかと
もうちょっと控えめた方が良かったんではないかとか
そんなこと言うんですよ
そこで控えている人にしてはね
この人は暗すぎやと もうちょっと明るく社会に出て仕事したらどうでしょうかね
どうでしょうかとかね
説教するんですよ だから中間の人はいつでもこの極端の内向性の人を批判する
外向性の人を批判する
でも自分問題抱えてるんですけどね
自分も結構自信があったりなかったり
だから逆に聞くと あんた自信あるのかって
そう言われても困りますよと言うんですよ
だからこの この極端性っていうのは目に入りやすい
例えば 15歳の男の子が親を殺したと
それでもうテレビやらマスコミやら大騒ぎで
もうもうもう報道するはするはするは
それで食べてるんですね
で それでこのテレビ見てるバカどもたちも
かなり社会のことを説明してくれると勘違いして
もうじーっと聞いてるんですけど
あれが極端な例で まあどんな 15歳の男の子も親殺すってことはしないでしょうね
極端もいいところでしょね
あんなのは だから あの
例えばもうもうそっちを転校することになったと
転校するはめになる子供っていうのは
それなりに結構いるでしょうね
それによって親殺したのありえないんですよ
あれが極端な例 それでこの人々
この極端な例だけ持ってきて
もうアメリカの FBI の心理学者の説明とかね
アメリカの CIA の元 CIA の誰かのもうもう説明とかね
もう世界一流の犯罪心理学者の意見聞くととかね
すべてくだらんですけどね
一つも役に立たないんで
あれで食べてるんですよ
何かもう  うん 人々はね
だからもうマスコミに出ない一般の方々も
この極端な例が出てくるとよく話題にする
私はそれは何とかしてちょうだいと言いたい
そんなのは誰にでも喋れますからね
15 歳の男の子が親 両親を殺しちゃうと
それはやっぱりびっくりしますよ
誰でも だからといっても
それが話題にしたっても何の役にも立ちません
もっとこの中間の人々は自分の問題を考えたらどうですかね
だってもう 100 万  200
100 100 万人というかね
まあどうかな 大体 10 万
20 万人ぐらいに 日本の極端な人っていうのは一人
二人  3人しかないんですよ
なんでそれだけ話題にするんですかね
例えば日本の社会で この青少年たちが犯罪を起こした例っていうのはね
もう過去 10年調べてみたくても
無数に出ますかね むちゃくちゃ大量に
ないでしょうに そんなたくさんないんです
まあワープロで打ったっても
A4 の 2枚  2ページぐらいで全部揃いますよ
なのにもう もうそればっかりハイライトして研究分析したってもね
だからもうその他大勢の人々のことを研究するの正しいのに
まあそれ問題もあります
問題は常識的な一般社会人たちなんですよ
この死にきれない者たちなんですよ
例えば内向性はもう何してるんですか？撃死する
外向性は昇進する 動きすぎて
もうもうとにかく死んでるんだからもう大丈夫ですよ
これで中間は死にきれないんですよ
だから問題はそちらにあるんですよ
一般一般社会人たちはうまくいっているのかいなかということが問題なんです
だって時々もう外向的で仕事をしていて
それは体にもう火を付けることだからね
それでガソリンをかけて体に火をつけちゃったんですけど
やっぱりこれが痛いんだからといって
また川に飛び込むでしょうね
でも泳げないんだから
これで溺れて死にかけたり
やっぱり溺れるんだから助けてくれと言って
また助けてもらっちゃうわけですね
助けてもらって またやっぱりと言って
また体にガソリンをかけて
また火を付ける で またまた川に飛び込むと
どちらにもなれないんですね
そんなもんで一生やってますから
死にきれないんですね
だから外向になったり
内向になったり 外向になったり
内向になったり そればっかりでやっててうまくいってないんですよ
はい